grella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo modo vi dò io sono fi j
oggi siamo sul surge simulator raga il
tè la terza operazione devo fare il
trapianto di cervello ci siamo arrivati
raga dopo secoli finalmente operazioni a
ragazze ragazzi avete lottato che non mi
hanno ancora chiamato impossibile
[Musica]
fantola ok ragazzi e mi sembrava strano
che non avessero ancora chiamato cioè ci
voleva
benissimo da ragazzi siamo partiti bene
ci voleva la chiamata perché sono non mi
sembrava normale e alla ragazzi
nell'ultima ps ti abbiamo visto il
trapianto di reni che purtroppo dopo tre
operazioni è fallito è comunque era
arrivato alla fine prima e trovo solo
spostare un rene e quindi praticamente
non lo sto a rifare faccio direttamente
il trapianto di cervello così i ragazzi
dal prossimo episodio ci sblocchiamo
quelli in ambulanza e come ultimo
ragazzi sarà fantastico
farò l'operazione nello spazio sarà
stupendo è però per ora va bene dire di
fare il trapianto di cervello ragazzi lo
aspettavo da secoli
ho sempre sognato di operare un cervello
oh mio dio
cos'è perché punto merck e questo è
quella di black ops perché il saggio e
un simulator nave non importa noi usiamo
questo è intanto raga è partito se
paranormal seghetto ma non ce ne frega
nulla ragazzi abbiamo avuto intanto
lascia il cervello ragazzi e fantastica
l'operazione al cervello epica alla
ragazzi bisogna impugnare saldamente
porca di quella [ __ ] me caduto il
time out
devo riuscire a riprenderlo devo
riuscire forse ce la fa forse ce la fa
un'edizione mustard cazzo ragazzi
intanto mi è caduto l'orologio di sotto
una roba assurda vabbè non mi importava
affanculo mi è caduto il pezzo forte
miur inizio non me ne frega niente deve
usarlo assolutamente va bene da ragazzi
devo effettuare questa operazione con la
massima serietà possibile perché cazzola
fanta è vuota che non voglio bere coca
cola mi hanno detto il medico mi ha
detto di non bere coca cola devo bene
fanta ma io sono un medico allora posso
fare quello che voglio
alla ragazze devo riuscire a tagliare il
cranio di questa povera vite di questo
povero paziente ora devo riuscire a
tagliare o sbagliata oddio salvina cup e
che salvi la paziente ma forse la che
gli ho tirato una accettata sulla nuca
ericsson dettagli quelli cioè tanto il
paziente non vede agli occhi chiusi
direi di procedere senti io so aprire le
uova non ho esperienza quei cervelli ma
soffrire le uova se è più o meno la
stessa cosa allora siamo a cavallo un
perfetto più o meno le apro così cazzo e
vabbè ragazzi allora studioso abbiamo
visto amore dove la siringa dove dove la
siringa dice questa è questa cazzo mi
sta morendo
guarda la donna sangue sta scendendo
troppo velocemente il sangue sta
scendendo il sangue stand dove no prendi
la carta maledice martello di merda
togliti ma che cazzo ma togliti mamma
letizia ormai donna santi dove 200 di
omicio posso far ciò posso farcela per
trovare afferra se in essa il nie
dall'altra parte idiota di merda della
zona
non ha senso non ha non ha senso fare la
siringa il paziente dalla parte opposta
ha un'utilità fantastica ragazzi è stata
la cosa più epica di sempre e minuti e
33 della mia vita più ben speso in
assoluto
poverino cazzo vabbè ragazzi voi lo
sapete il primo paziente è sempre quello
più sfortunato è anche secondo a dir la
verità è che hanno ragazzi possiamo
iniziare seriamente abbiamo iniziato
divertendo ma che cazzo ma perché non
riesca a tenere una è l'unico strumento
che dà fino ad ora non son riuscito a
tenere decentemente allora apriamo non
riesco a chiudere ok perfetto uscite non
riuscivo a chiudere le dita dicevo
apriamo i crani alla vecchia maniera
vai cos'è marassi sbatti quel cane come
se stessi giocando da chi a palata alpa
vai così vai cos'è mamma mia che che
tornato sarebbe fiero di te
venissa morendo cosa non sta morendo
fortunatamente ce la facciamo forse ci
riesco a nome ucciderlo prima del tempo
ci ha fatto ok perfetto
sì la cosa è fattibile però stiamo
ragazzi sta morendo c'è l'operazione al
cervello delicatissimo perché
praticamente solo tocchi male perde più
sangue lui di non so cosa giustamente il
cervello non è che sia una roba che
cazzo devo riuscire a prendere una
siringa chiudi le dita cure donna
santissimo una siringa devi prendere
chiudevi chiudere le dita cazzo che
impedito ci riesce meglio lui che non
sta guarda che ok vediamo se riusciamo a
fare una siringa come si deve
nell'occhio
se ha funzionato alla ragazzi questa è
un'operazione delicatissima mi sembra di
essere in una tortura di soho clara
trappola per orsi che mette in testa ai
trenta secondi per liberarsi se non
sotto favi genti staccherà il cranio
veramente io l'ho già staccato il cranio
devo riuscire soltanto a toglierli il
cervello come glielo tolgo allo ragazzi
devo effettuare al cervello nuovo e qui
allora adesso devo riuscire ad aprire il
cranio come cazzo si fa
sono io qui il dottore non dovrei dire
queste cose lo so se tizio io non so
bene come si si opera al cervello come
te lo posso togliere ma voi per caso una
fanta no perché qui avanza
ok perfetto non è esattamente quello che
dovrei fare
va bene come glielo svitto il cervello
ti giuro che non volevo rimettiti come
di prima ma statevi me perfetto cos'è
cos'è successo perché gli il sito il
cervello e ragazzi siamo riusciti e chi
è che adesso ci siamo allora devo
riuscire a staccare il cervello perfetto
quindi direi che il cervello va rimosso
con un qualcosa di decente che non sia
l'ascia da guerra una rara ragazzi piano
piano piano piano che questo mischiata
ce l'abbiamo fatta
questo è il classico caso di paziente
senza cervello è la ragazzi l'ultima
cosa da fare prima di inserire il
cervello e vedere se ci sono le pirlo
cazzo non ci sono le pillole allora
direi di inserire semplicemente il
barattolo perfetto ragazzi ci siamo
allora adesso il nostro paziente è
pronto è pronto per dare dimostrazione
della sua intelligenza è giunto il
momento di coprire ragazzi mi sembrava
vietnamita qualcosa in testa che è che
la testa e ha posto quindi dovrei
riuscire a inserire il cervello prima
che questo che mi diventi completamente
rincitrullito allora le mani dove devono
essere messa all'interno della perché mi
si incastra il pollice maledizione
allora ragazzi
l'ultima fase della nostra operazione
come avete potuto appurare è molto ma
molto delicata bisogna inserire il
cervello è stata un'impresa titanica
presto è stato l'assoluto
l'operazione più nonsense di tutte alla
ragazzi visto che hai discapito del
durato poco direi di dare soltanto un
occhiata alle operazioni in ambulanza
giusto per vedere come sono adesso vedo
se magari ne farò anche di più in un
solo episodio visto che ormai so come
sia come si come si fanno le operazioni
perché sono ormai un dottore
professionista però per correttezza
voglio vedere come diciamo allora
vediamo se riesco a togliere sta roba
ok ragazzi e soprattutto otto ragazze si
fa a fare un'operazione in ambulanza
così no ma che cazzo si aperto il retro
o mio dio ragazzi chiudendo ragazzi sia
per torre l'anno non guardi e via
tranquilla se abbiamo preso una buca ma
stia tranquillo a lui lei non guai non
guardi sta se lei e sulle montagne russe
sta sognando di essere sulle montagne
russe
no guardi dietro non guardi dietro che
c'è qualcosa che non vorrebbe vedere tra
l'altro ragazzi è saltato il cuore cioè
io storia non può superare in queste
condizioni è impossibile doma mio dio i
ragazzi ma se mi scappa il cuore dal
dall'ambulanza come oddio perché c'è un
estintore perché c'è un estintore
ragazze spiegatemi che cosa ci devo fare
con un estintore
il cast c in questa situazione ceci
spacco il torace se spacchiamo altre
ragazze sarà uno spazio sono sicuro sarà
fenosa e casadei è l'estintore
l'attrezzo giusto altro che martello
guarda qui vuoi un po cazzo si è chiusa
la porta come cazzo ha fatto a chiudersi
c'è la rispondiamo e la rispondiamo la
rispondiamo cos'è è crollato laser c'è
anche c'è c'è anche laser in ambulanza
ragazzi non ci ho parole
oddio se riaperto tutto ragazzi è secca
dell'estintore pica c'è un'esplosione
oddio ragazzi se passa qualche macchina
esplode tutto è un disastro
vabbè io direi ragazzi che per questo
episodio posso concludere qui sarà
fantastico comunque ragazzi come al
solito se vi dove è piaciuto lasciato un
commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come in ogni video trovate
nella descrizione se non siete ancora i
cibi scrivete bene ci vediamo in un
prossimo
ma la ragazza
[Musica]